in math there are a few common
pronunciation mistakes we all make how
do we pronounce this number can you tell
me
let's see we have 4 expressions here and
we shall see how to pronounce each
expression this expression is pronounced
as 5 minus 2 this number which is 2 with
the negative sign
we shall not pronounce it as minus 2 in
straight we pronounce it as negative 2
this expression will be pronounced as 7
plus negative 2 and this expression will
be pronounced as negative 2 over 3
so this term negative is the identity of
a number we will use minus only when it
is an operation of subtraction before
leaving do tell us how you will
pronounce these three expressions